[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 155 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
my name is Mark Mandel and I'm here with
my colleague this week I'm joined by a
very special guest Michelle Kass fun how
you doing Michelle I'm doing great how
are you mark I'm very well thank you
very much for for standing in famila
knee this week and joining me on the
podcast it's fantastic to be here my
first time co-hosting excellent well
just like every week this week we're
going to be talking about an interview
with confluent we're gonna be talking to
them about Kefka and message processing
systems after that we'll be doing our
question of the week where we'll be
asking if I wanted to submit a CFP or a
call for papers for next 2019 how would
I do it how would you do I don't know
but I believe you have the answer there
are a lot of answers to that question
it's well documented on our website
excellent and we will talk about that
before we do that we're gonna get stuck
into cool things of the week and I know
you have some cute flow stuff yes I have
lots of really good cute flow news so it
has been a very big year for cute flow
it is coming up on its one-year
anniversary the project was launched
just under a year ago this was an
action-packed week one of my favorite
things last week we published a guide to
inclusivity yes this is a guide for
leaders of the cue flow project and its
really pretty generic I think it applies
to any open source project really any
tech related project it's open source
it's on the github repo at github com /
qø / community yes
it's inclusive lead up markdown and it's
just a few examples of things that we do
within the cube flow community to make
sure that everyone feels welcome and
it's really beneficial to not just
underrepresented groups but really for
everyone I think I'll steal that but it
sounds really good please do that's why
it's there an open source
excellent we'll have a link in the show
notes we also have a really great
article talking about how New York Times
is using Google cloud do you find untold
stories and millions of archive photos
so they have a huge swath of images from
a variety of sources and a huge amount
of history and they're building out a
asset management system that uses cloud
storage pub/sub machine learning through
the vision API basically to take all
these images and catalog them and find
out all sorts of interesting stuff in
there it's actually
really cool article we should check it
out yes great and didn't they call this
the morgue wasn't this like a basement
full of images that they're digitizing
really I didn't think I'd call it that
that's a delightfully doc name yes and
it's like improving access to things
inside the morgue which everyone gets
excited all right so the other cool
thing so more cute flow news we just
released something called click to
deploy which gives you everything you
need to get started with cue flow it
helps you to deploy your whole
infrastructure and install all of the
cue flow files onto a gke cluster yes
and it's just a pretty simple website
deploy keep slowed cloud and typing your
project name add your OAuth credentials
boom you're done takes about 15 minutes
to spin up it'll give you a domain name
to access everything inside the cluster
much simpler all of a very detailed
steps you used to have to go through so
again big news for queue flow very nice
excellent another cool thing I would be
remiss if I didn't talk about kubernetes
so container D which is an industry
standard container runtime and basically
the core part of dunkers core runtime
process if you want to try container d
on google kubernetes engine it's
available for beta testing now basically
if you want to just test your workflows
make sure everything works the way it
should do you can do that basically by
saying like there's a particular
container operating system image type
that you can use inside your gke startup
scripts and that'll start up the beta
version that uses container D rather
than the full docker stack so it's got
some nice things about it basically
great fits but it's been to be embedded
a smaller resource footprint that kind
of stuff so if you want to take ever
spin and see how it works it's available
for you now silence great I promise is
the last Q news so this was this is the
biggest news of the week and this was an
announcement a few new things one of
them is the AI hub and the other is
pipelines these are important because
it's a way to interact with queue flow
that doesn't involve getting down to the
kubernetes level and using cube CTO and
worrying about pods so pipelines
provides the Python SDK gives you a way
to from within a notebook to define an
entire machine learning workflow and
then there's a really nice fancy UI so
you can see things running and see the
status you can view your pod
from within this really nice UI and then
the AI hub is where you can find sort of
generic components to bring into your
pipeline to make it easier to start from
scratch with a few sort of pre-baked
things and those are both public objects
and private so if you're within an
organization you can have things just
for you and your group so lots of lots
of room for growth there it's brand new
it just opened up I believe it's in
alpha release so if you want to get
started I believe there's a link to sign
up for that awesome and finally this is
something that I've actually really
wanted for a really really long time and
I'm so glad to see it cloud scheduler is
available so basically if you've ever
wanted to run anything on Google cloud
platform on a regular basis without
having to start up like a VM with cron
or just create a simple App Engine app
just to do Chrome scripting we now have
a thing that does this and it's really
good so there's a job scheduler you set
it up it actually uses the same chrome
tab type format but basically if you
want to push an event to an HTTP
endpoint or at a pub sub and you want to
do on a regular basis you can now do it
through cloud scheduler and you can go
play with it now and it works and it
does cool stuff so no more having to
build these little App Engine apps just
to do Chrome stuff nice so you can
upload your like asterisk commands
directly to the cloud schedule or not to
worry about building a whole app around
it now you have to build a whole app
it's just a little thing that does the
thing that's supposed to do nice is
there a good GUI for to do I have to
still speak in asterisk language there
is a GUI for it so you can do that in
there as well the frequency is still in
asterisk language in like crontab but we
have guides for that as well wonderful
yeah it's not too bad
awesome so why don't we go chat with
Victor about confluent and Kafka sounds
great let's do it
thanks so much to victor gamma for
coming to join us today developer
advocate for a confluent victor how you
doing hi guys very excited to be here
longtime listener first-time caller I
think actually you're the first one to
make that joke thanks so much for coming
down to talk to us about confluent and
Kafka before we get stuck into that tell
us about who you are and what do you do
I'm a developer advocate at confluence
what I do I like to talk to developers
engineers administrators architects
about Kafka and shimming platform it's
like very short what we can you know
dive deeper if needed so can you tell us
what is Kafka prepared yeah essentially
Kafka is what we call streaming platform
and interesting enough that when you
talk to people depends on who you're
talking to if you're talking to people
who has a messaging background they can
feel that oh it looks like new messaging
solution if you talk to people who has
data bases background they might say oh
it looks like distributed database
because of the nature of the data that
we're putting there so Kafka is a very
unique beast in the world of distributed
systems but essentially what we call
it's a streaming platform that allows
you to not only consume news alerts in
real time but also do processing because
usually Kafka as a as a project is a
patch project includes multiple things
the brokers itself stream processing
library called Kafka streams in the
library that allows to easy integration
web data sources called Kafka connected
so this is a very short version but
again we can go as deep as you want and
as deep as your listeners want to
absolutely so what sort of things do
people tend to use Kafka for I mean you
mentioned that some people think very in
one way and other people think of it
another what are some typical use cases
when the Kafka was developed back in the
day and a link to him they tried to
solve one of the problems to increase
speed of data ingestion into Hadoop and
they start to move from the batch
oriented pipelines where they need to
wait until all data will arrive into
some like landing area where they can
start processing to the more like okay
do we really need to wait for all this
data because our algorithms not
necessarily need to have it you know in
one place so we can do this and process
this data as it comes
so this is where idea of stream
processing and essentially like infinite
stream of data that comes into the
system where we can process this data as
it pumps instead of having this buffered
or after that we can process at the end
of the day so this is one of the use
case where the people start using this
in the very limited capacity they
started okay so if we will stream our
logs there because usually logs it's
important data but it's not that
important that's actually like
transactional data in so far and so on
so the log processing was one of the use
case
were people starting to look into Kafka
over the time people start realizing
that he is actually we can use it to
solving some of the real-time use cases
where we have data that comes in the big
amounts and the high velocity so the
Kafka helps to absorb this so Kafka
behaves as an insurer buffer plus
libraries allows to process data as it
arise now use cases around Kafka pretty
much are limitless
Kafka even used for the backbone for
micro-services when you need to
establish communication between
different micro-services components
without actually tightly coupling them
how does it buffer like what can you
give us just a conceptual idea of what
that really means
so Kafka itself represents data
structure that called append-only log or
distributed append-only log meaning that
data always will be reading to the end
of the file which allows to very fast
right capabilities and also can be read
sequentially so all consumers to read
the data from begin over file and there
is this sequentially that also allows
very fast speed in terms of consumption
this is why Kafka looks like or sounds
like messaging queue for many people
because in messaging queue your messages
comes in one place and reading from
another and all right so it's like a
first in first down type of data
structure that's why it's also suitable
for messaging use cases Kafka provides
the ways how this data can be replicated
in case of one of the brokers will go
down provides the way how these topics
what we call topics data structure where
everyone is reading and writing and the
topics allows us to topic is partition
so this one was talking about data
structures that lies inside the Kafka
they remind some no sequel type of
database where you know you can have a
horizontal scalability
and you can scale your topics by just
adding more brokers and essentially it
provides also replicas in case of
failures there are any kinds of limits
and the type of information that can go
into Kafka or is it kind of just like
throw whatever you want in there to get
processed essentially there is no limit
but conceptually there is so as a
streaming platform Kafka is design
and to be handling large number of
messages but the size of messages should
be relatively small so this is why if
you're trying to stream files like a
hundred of megabytes of file as one
message maybe it's not very suitable so
this is why people come up with
different workarounds if they still can
use this case or one implement this use
case so you can chunk this file and send
this in different chunks probably if we
talk about streaming people usually
talking about streaming video or
streaming audio so Kafka is not
specifically a good case for that kind
of payloads so I would say a large
number of messages high velocity this is
the perfect type of payload but inside
the message it really doesn't matter
what you put in there so data is of
course key nowadays and being able to
manage it of course is very important
where does Kafka plug in in terms of
integrate in the various data tooling
and products that exist out there what
are all the things that integrates into
the major the use case what I see right
now I used to work in the professional
services with confluent so I was talking
many customers about their use cases and
the things how they want to use it and
specifically when we're talking about
data integration change data capture use
case is on a high demand so imagine you
have things like Oracle database where
you want to extract the changes and make
them like real-time so when we're
talking about usually traditional
databases it's kind of like a solid
source of data but we want to provide a
little bit of fluidity we need to start
moving data out so having these
connectors that was written using Kafka
Connect framework can extract this or
like a listen the changes that happen in
Oracle database and push these changes
into Kafka so once you kind of broke
this silo off like with your Oracle
database your data becomes available for
many sources so Kafka designed to be
very heavy on reads you know this is why
you have this kind of literature
illusion to you know the Franz Kafka is
the famous writer test so when you know
someone wrote this once and many people
can read this so same thing with Kraft
so once you extract this data from this
data silo as a traditional
relational database and start moving
data out and in this case you open up
multiple different possibilities for
integration
you know connectors can be two types one
can bring data in in another can take
data out so once you extract this from
Oracle you can do processing in craft
using Kafka streams or key sequel and
after that offload this data to [ __ ] to
elastic or even to any cloud storage one
of the use case that we see right now
it's kind of making Kafka as a I don't
want to sound too marketing but like
it's kind of like a bridge to cloud
sorry about that but essentially one of
the company that I was working instead
of paying vendors to provide them ways
how they can do replication and gonna be
very expensive they use Kafka CGC to
change the capture of their own pram
database and replicated to their Google
cloud platform instances so so if
someone needs to like build a connector
or they want to build their own like
custom integration or is there like
api's or like client libraries for
different languages how does that work
usually what I try to say before you
start building something and short
answer to your question yes yeah but
before you start building something you
need to check if there is a connector
already available because the framework
itself it's quite popular for building
connectors there is a one common place
where everyone can go away and publish
their connectors called confluent hub so
if you go to conference io / hub you
will find all possible connectors
vehicle if you want to build this it
will require some of the skills
specifically Java skills so if you want
to build the connector there is a
framework rafter connectors
documentation around this there's some
examples of how to build connector I
would say like it's fairly simple like I
build connector myself so I can say then
I'm not the brightest engineer or like
smartest engineer I can build connector
so everyone can build connected so API
is quite straightforward you just need
to figure out how you want you you know
read data out of Kafka or write data to
Kafka and there's pretty much it
however if you don't want to for some
reason learn Java and or like API for
your data source is not available for
Java you can still stick to traditional
producer/consumer clients there are
plenty and native integration for any
possible language so
java.net no GS c-sharp C++ it just tell
me when I need to stop all the things
okay so I understand that there is an
open-source version of Kafka and there's
also an Enterprise version so what makes
them different and what makes them is
the same so I would say this is not very
precisely accurate statement because
Kafka itself is open-source there's no
Enterprise version of Kafka so what we
do in confluent we actually building
trimming platform that augments basic
things that provides by Kafka brokers
clients have to connect in Kafka streams
with some additional capabilities that
enterprises need so this why we build
two things we build the confluent
platform open source and the confluent
enterprise so for open source platform
we include the things for managing
scheme offer data managing metadata
around this data called schema registry
that allows you to have a centralized
place where we can store all these
schemas of the data and provide
different versions so one micro service
can not have this data like some billion
application they can always request this
from schema registry we provide a rest
proxy which is in very rare occasion
where you cannot use native clients you
can use a rest proxy so for example
you're writing Kafka client in bash and
using curl to interact with Kafka so you
can use the rasp proxy to do that and
the third one I guess very cool thing is
the case sequel which is stream
processing tool that allows you to use
sequel to write your stream processing
applications how do you write sequel to
do stream processing how does that work
so we were thinking that okay how we can
elaborate the stream processing and open
up to like a wider audience and we
figure out that the most used language
or most used technology in data world is
sequel so we said okay let's see how we
can use a sequel language as a DSL for
shrimp processing so essentially we took
some of the concept that people already
know do your select and you like
filtering by in particular fields and we
built a tool called key sequel so we
have a stream infinite stream
of credit card transactions but you only
interested in data that happened with
one account within five second interval
so you have a multiple swipes so you can
potentially say okay so maybe it's a
fraudulent account within five second
interval so case equal allows you to
write a simple sequel statement on
infinite stream of data that will
produce another stream that will include
all the data that you interested so for
example from the stream of credit card
transactions we can produce stream that
will have potential fraudulent
transactions that will include all
messages where credit card number ID
will be swiped three times or five times
within 5 mins interval so it's it's kind
of a powerful thing because it includes
what we call stateful stream processing
because in order to do like a count how
many types you swiped a credit card you
need to have a result from the previous
message right so you need to have it
store it somewhere you need to have a
state and also you need to have a state
that will be applicable to a particular
time window window is essentially a
concept that allows you to build kind of
finished
data chunks on infinite stream of data
and everything was done thanks to
grafica stream so key sequel is built on
two of kafka streams which is java
library but as the developer you don't
need to learn java or any other language
just use sequel to write your
application I'm not sure if I answer
this fully but essentially there's
couple extensions that you need to know
because in standard sequel there's no
like stream concept there's no window
concept however if you want you to join
us for example you have data that comes
with the stream and you have some data
that you extracted from your database in
this dating inside the Kafka you can
join those two streams in order to
produce in the rich stream you have a
stream that only includes credit-card
number information and you have another
stream that has credit card number and
all fields that is required to know who
the owner of the credit card was the
balance and things like that so you're
joining two streams in order to produce
third stream which would be you know
documented stream and to quickly return
to the question about enterprise
platform so enterprise platform includes
some of the monitoring tools
I'm advanced tools for data replication
and essentially it's also built on top
of open-source Kafka on top of open
source platform and provides some of the
enterprise tools like for monitoring for
example control center and some of the
connectors for enterprise systems but
Kafka itself it's fully open source and
there's no difference between enterprise
platform and open source Kafka great so
what is the relationship between con
fluid and the Kafka project so the
confluent was founded by three people
that came from LinkedIn and those people
were active contributors to Apache Kafka
projects so J Krebs was one of the
masterminds behind some of the
distributed systems in LinkedIn and the
Kafka was included and one of the most
popular project is Kafka so he helped to
bring this to a patches of the
foundation and after that when the
project was very popular in Netaji they
decided to start a company to provide
Shrimant platform on top of Apache Kafka
that will have all features of open
source thing but also will have advanced
features and tools that modern
enterprise required for example like for
data governance schema registry or for
providing simplicity of frame processing
providing a casing so far so on so we
right now
I don't remember exact number but
confluent is largest contributor to open
source of magic Kafka so we have
engineers who work on on pushing the
bits and bytes to Apache Kafka so this
is the Google cloud platform podcast
what's the relationship between
confluence and Google Cloud at the
moment I would say maybe two years ago
we started getting like a lot of
requests from customers saying that hey
so it would be great if there would be a
manage the Kafka
I'm sorry kind of I'm starting from a
little bit of history that's again to
put some of the context in place so and
the customers are saying yeah what would
be great to have manage Kafka because
Ouisa enterprises want to focus on
getting fast into cloud and getting fast
into solving our business problems
rather than building infrastructure so
we start building what we call the
confluent cloud which is essentially
fully
managed the solution for running not
only Apache Kafka but fool confluent
platform so one of the things that we
had in mind is that we don't want people
manage anything like that you don't need
to gives us your account information
like if you want ours to run on your
hardware so we can say yes we can run
Kafka and confluent platform in any
public cloud provider so pick and choose
so we released everything in AWS and
last year was huge success of lunch a
long-awaited lunch of confluent cloud
and Google cloud platform some of the
things that we initially build for this
platform was rejected to support running
into multiple cloud environments for
example so essentially we run everything
in kubernetes so kubernetes is our like
a weapon of choice Mark's doing a happy
dance about Karina they keep this the
kubernetes thing on the back burner we
have some news around this as well when
we move to another cloud from from a SS
we actually had to like eject a lot of
things because a lot of things were easy
to do in a SS some of the things were
easy to do in Google glass for example
like to spin up the kubernetes cluster
is much easier in a Google cloud
platform or like to configure some of
the things because simply it was more
popular AWS has some certain defi I to
do load balancing but right now it's a
parity so when you go to confident cloud
and you want to spin up your Kafka can
say hey I wanna run it in my Google
cloud you can just select region and
after that you're good to go so you
don't need to think where this is
running you just have a connection
string to Kafka and this is pretty much
it
another thing that I mentioned about the
kubernetes is that we internally gained
a lot of experience by running this at
scale and some of the customers like
more conservative customers are saying
hey yeah the cloud is cool but how I
would have the same things that the
cloud provides but also internally so we
have like internal tasks for example
we're running something like open source
kubernetes or when it will be available
publicly we can run like a DCP on Prem
how we can run the Kafka same way as you
do guys so this is why we also invested
to product called the confluent operator
that allows you to
just deal with your requirements about
Kafka you don't need to think about this
what's the stateful set what's your
service what's the headless service how
to expose your craft outside world how
to build load balancer so operator
inside kubernetes will do same thing as
it does in our cloud but it allows the
customers to run this in their data
center on Prem or I'm literally just
looked up the website it says here
available soon is that all you can say
yeah it will be available hopefully on
the beginning of the year 2019 so right
now we on board a few customers will run
very rigorous early access program we're
running some of the you know some edge
cases to make sure that product would
meet all expectations I already kind of
like a start playing with this myself I
also presented this in the few
conferences it looks pretty awesome in
order to provide like a best experience
we just need to have a little more
testing with some of our partners and
some of the customers yes
personally again no one paid me for this
but I personally use UCP for all my
tests because again right now it's best
experience if you want to have
kubernetes in public cloud is GCP thank
you so love it use it personally awesome
that sounds like you're building some
amazing stuff
what can we sort of expect from Kafka
and come fluent in the future I mean you
mentioned the operators but is there any
other neat stuff coming in the pipeline
that people might want to know about
this very good question so we still
continue to pushing boundaries of what
the key sequel can do some advanced
semantics supporting some advanced
schemas so right now can sequel allows
you to you know without any interference
k sequel allows to deal with JSON Avro
and planes and some of the like comma
separated data for thinking to have more
schemas coming for example G RPC and the
Google protocol buffers is very popular
format tween services we're thinking to
support this and we have a lot of
requests from customers in terms of
cloud we keep pushing some of the
observability elements in confluent
cloud providing metrics you can see how
fast this data is is going through
what's the all possible metrics that
your application can depend on
planning to have full management
platform with all bits and bytes of
confluent platform will be in our cloud
and most importantly we're planning to
have free tier for our kavkaza service
so when you want to start learning
things you don't need to have data
center to spin up this you just go there
run your Kafka grab some of the
libraries my team is responsible for
helping developers to have enough
examples to have enough documentation in
order to start with Kafka and we
actually pretty excited when we will
release free version of cloud so we can
talk more about libraries languages I'm
pretty excited to talk about go clients
myself I start go development recently a
that's great
if I wanted to contribute to actually
building out Kafka since it's open
source how can I do that so if you want
to contribute to Apache Kafka it's great
that the products like Kafka in Hadoop
they placed and well established
software foundation that has certain
rules about how you do things and
there's actually like very clear ways
how you can contribute you start by
finding some issues in JIRA JIRA is
public you can go there's guts Kafka
JIRA in Apache you start looking for
some issues you can go there comments
and hey I'm interested to fix this
problem so you start working on the
thing you either providing patch or you
creating pull requests because
development also happened in github so
there is Apache mirror or off repository
so you can you can also do development
in github
so you're providing your patch you
discuss through code review you discuss
with contributors one of the
contributors or committers they can be
your guide so they can explain like
what's the what you're doing this if
everything is ok everyone is the case
your pull request will be merged so over
the time you will gain more power
computer you can become a committer and
can start sent more patches and over the
time you can even start your own if you
want to introduce a new feature some
introduce some new piece of
functionality you can start your own
called account Kafka improvement
proposal or keep where can discuss some
of the design decisions or some new
features and
think about usual people also asking me
like if I want to learn some internals
if I want to learn how different
functionality works how I can you know
learn this and you can go and read there
certain keeps because keep is
essentially your blueprint for a certain
functionality like very cool way how you
can learn from the source and thought
process like there's also some of the
design decisions that were ejected also
mentioned it's also pretty cool if you
want to contribute to the confident open
source platform it's or like a sequel
it's less strict so essentially go there
for Kasich wall send your pool request
you will discuss with engineers and just
need to sign contributed agreement and
pretty much it sweet if people want to
learn more about Kafka or come fluent
why should they go so I would say they
need to go just become fluent dot IO and
we're working right now with probably
you should expect this in 2019 somewhere
we're working on some landing page for
developers the architects and
administrators but right now confer at
i/o it's a great landing page I would
highly recommend to subscribe to our
blog trying to share not only our
success stories but also some of the
customers they contribute to our blog
some of the individual contributors they
also write for us so our blog you can
see there is like a very good source of
all sorts of information starting from
some internals about Kafka so June rau
is one of the cofounders of confluent
and one of the core committers to Kafka
he has like a very famous blog about how
to choose number of partitions and even
like Google when you do Google search
you will find that this blog faster that
you will find actual in documentation so
it's very popular in the highly regarded
blog post we have interesting use cases
from some customers one of the popular
blog posts is from New York Times and
how they use Kafka to store all the data
or like all the publish the materials
that they have on their website they
stored inside the Kafka topic so also
pretty cool and you're looking at the
Google some of the use cases and most
likely you will end up in the confluent
blog I would say the best place to start
great
Viktor thank you so much for coming on
is there anything else that you wanted
to cover before we let you go oh thank
you so much for having me here
it was super excited for my site you
know thank
so you came well-prepared with all the
questions hopefully I answered those one
of the things that I want to mention is
that would you run a community slack
channel so inside this you can go there
you have multiple rooms in different
topics if you want to talk about
kubernetes if you want to talk about
dumb containers if you want to talk
about shrimp processing we do have
educated the rooms there where not only
our engineers hang out sometimes but
also like you have a power of community
we have over you know couple thousand
people there but maybe not like in the
same time but at least there's a place
where you can you know browse some
history find some some answers ask
questions and and things like that I
think this is a great place and
specifically if you want to have some
in-person presence we'll also have this
chat room called events where we publish
all meetups that happened around the
kafka around streaming all different
events fantastic well Victor yeah thank
you so much for joining us and talking
to us about Kafka and confluent thank
you very much thank you so thank you
very much to victor joining us today to
talk to us about Kafka about Kafka or
Kafka
what is the correct pronunciation I
don't want I always say Kafka that's
what my friend Gwen Shapiro always tells
me okay I trust Quinn's pronunciation of
her own company's product pronounced
Kafka like cough drops or coffee that
seems pretty reasonable that's what this
is what happens when you only see things
on the internet and you don't know
whether or not they're real things in
real life
you should meet Gwen if you ever have a
chance she's lovely wonderful would they
like to come on the podcast Oh perhaps I
could convince her excellent
anyways moving along we talking about
Kafka and thank you sir let's get a
second to our question of the week so I
do hear that cloud next 2019 is coming
up and I would really like to submit
something so that I can present so is
there a coal for papers can I submit how
do I do this there is there's a whole
website you can find the link in the
show notes there's a ton of information
on this page so this will be my first
next CFP and so I just this weekend was
looking over all of the guidelines tips
and tricks so I will share some of the I
think most useful advice so the first
thing you want to keep in mind is that
it's not really about just describing
some cool project that you've done you
want
focus on what people can get out of your
talk so what are the main things that
they will learn after they've visited
your session this is how you draw people
in this is how you make it compelling
and you want to focus on either a
beginner level intermediate or advanced
but be very clear about what you'll be
covering and how many prerequisites are
involved so the word counts are actually
pretty short on this which I appreciate
especially as someone who has mean nuts
I can't stuff it right long things yes
you are pretty bad about following the
word count limits but this one it's like
250 words for your abstract it's a
really short but that makes it a lot
easier and harder to submit your your
abstract I'm terrified so you want to be
very efficient with your words like
high-impact heavy hitting what are you
gonna teach what are the big takeaways
when I read abstracts I have a formula
that I like to use that I think is
worked reasonably well which is what is
the problem
what is the solution and then in this
talk what are you gonna show and I find
that works reasonably well so like in
some planets you can't pet dogs so today
we're gonna talk about how we can bring
dogs to your planet in this talk we'll
talk about bringing dogs to planets and
the problems you may run into like that
is literally what my abstract nice so
you're hoping to draw on people who live
on planets with no dogs exactly and it's
and it's there and the abstract is very
clear they know exactly that they belong
in that session and they know exactly
what they're gonna get out of it I find
that that's it that's a formula I've
used a lot over the years yeah that's a
good model and if you want to see
examples of abstracts that have been
accepted there's a whole PDF with about
a dozen examples for you to use as a
guide and so whatever whatever subject
area you think is most interesting
preferably it has a Google product in it
it is a Google conference suite yeah so
you have about a month to submit this
deadline is December 7th so get your
ideas together and make sure you get it
in in time I'm putting it it's only 250
words so there's not a whole lot of
effort involved in submitting and who
knows maybe it'll get accepted and we'll
see you there in April that would be
lovely
awesome well where are you gonna be what
do you what are you up to what events
you up to Michelle let's see this week
so Friday
is I think Wednesday Thursday and Friday
is scaled by the bay so on Friday I will
be at a panel and AI and data
engineering panel so you can find me
there I'll be there with a couple of my
good friends Pete's Kamaraj and Lucas be
bald a couple of other people so if
you're at scale by the way come find me
I'll be talking what else
cute flow excellent and I believe you're
also traveling down to Australia that's
right so just after Thanksgiving I'll be
leaving for Sydney and I'll be involved
in a conference called yow I'll be
giving a talk on what else you bless you
flow and so I'll be in Sydney and then a
few days later I'll be travelling to
Brisbane and then Melbourne so if you're
in any of those three cities please come
find me and be great to say hello shout
out to all my Australian friends you
should totally listen to Michelle
absolutely everyone kilo is a very
interesting topic and I make it very
intriguing because I talk about how it's
like a paper airplane like oh that
sounds good now I want to hear you so I
know you're also gonna be a cube Khan
with me what are you going to be talking
about what else hopefully giving a
workshop on cube blow yeah end-to-end
cube flow so pretty beginner take you
through the installation process and a
basic sort of training serving you I
prediction and giving you a codelab so a
full workshop giving you an environment
to run it in hands-on our colleague Amy
and I will both be doing that together I
keep gone excellent well I will also be
there talking about it gonna and Game
Servers and that kind of fun stuff as
well nice awesome
well Michelle thank you for joining me
this week on today's podcast it was
great to be here I look forward to many
more with you excellent and thank you
all for listening and we'll see you all
next week
[Music]
you